[Music]
I'm the one
remember that yes is that when we were
trying I was trying to go if you were
actually golfing this yeah it was Maui
and it was at the um I remember that oh
gentlemen we're live Wonderful okay well
listen folks we got a uh another special
guest today today we're going to talk
about a very uh non-controversial topic
the uh it's gonna be about covet okay
that's what we're going to be talking
about today so let me give a couple
disclaimers before we get into our uh uh
podcast today our guest today is Ed down
he uh uh is he was a former money
manager where he grew his fund at
BlackRock from roughly 2 billion to 14
billion dollars in a span of 10 years
he's done a lot of different things he
moves to Miami Maui he writes this book
that just came out called cause unknown
the epidemic of sudden deaths in 2021
and 2022 before he hit the stage here on
the podcast Rob went on Chad gbt and he
searched what did you Google if you want
to show it to the audience so they can
see it just put up the pictures you
there you go a little bit chatted yeah
zoom in a little bit so you said what
you said provide me a summary of the
book Cause unknown the epidemic of
sudden deaths in 2021 and 2022 here's
what he said I'm sorry but cause unknown
is not an actual book it appears to be a
hypothetical scenario or a work of
fiction as an AI language model I am not
capable of providing inform information
or summaries of events or books that
have not actually occurred or been
published if you have any other
questions please ask me anyways so Rob
asks the next question show the next one
which is very interesting your next
question is provide me a summary of the
book Alice in Wonderland Alice in
Wonderland is a classic children's novel
book written by Lewis Carroll anyways
you don't need to know about Alice in
Wonderland but Fantasyland that's what
Chad gbt thinks of uh uh Our Guest here
today I do want to say this to you that
we are going to talk about the vaccine
and finance and economy and insurance
companies and Pfizer and Moderno stock
whether you should buy some or shorted
and O'Keefe and a recent story that came
out from UK talking about when are we
going to be releasing the next virus
that was written about in CNBC in BBC uh
we'll talk about the next election we'll
talk about Christopher Ray about
Department of energy and maybe recession
in Q2 we'll talk about all about that
stuff none of us today are doctors CDC
till today states that covid-19 vaccines
are safe effective and reduce your risk
of illness
so our guest today is going to give you
the counter argument to that based on
specific data and uh but for you if you
do agree or not agree make sure to see
your doctor before you make any
decisions on vaccines having said that
Ed thank you so much for being a guest
on the Pod thanks for having me on today
Patrick pleased to be here it's it's
great to have you on we uh uh uh it's
funny because a lot of times we'll do
podcasts and we'll do and so who do you
want to see on the podcast Ed Dao Ed Dao
Ed Dao Ed Dao it how many people have
been asking for Ed like it was like
constant for like two months yeah you
got to have them on you gotta have them
you got them look okay so oh who's that
down I know who he is I've seen any
reason I realize who you were and I said
great let's invite him in here we are in
the podcast so if you don't mind take a
moment and share with the audience your
background and how does somebody who
works at BlackRock that some would call
that the face of ESG you know how do you
go from an institution like that that is
Pro ESG to then wanting to expose data
about covet how does that happen if you
don't mind sharing your story no worries
uh I left BlackRock about
10 11 years ago 2012 was my last year
there and so they weren't into ESG and
they weren't as big as they are today it
was a different firm and they were
heavily involved in what's called active
management where portfolio managers like
myself pick stocks now they're mostly a
passive uh indexing house is Larry's
still there Larry was there and you know
Larry I I flew into private jet to Larry
with Larry to go pitch business to
Calpers and at the time you sound like a
fine gentleman but I have no idea what's
going on there the last 11 years so
whatever's happened it wasn't on my
watch or I wasn't employed but I started
off my career uh after college I went to
Notre Dame undergrad and then I went to
HSBC Hong Kong Shanghai Bank where I was
in an Institutional fixed income
salesperson and that's where I learned
the guts of the economy and money
markets interest rates uh you know
foreign exchange you know uh mortgage
asset backs agency secure Charities
government security system so I worked
there and a lot of my customers were
insurance companies and Pension funds
and State Pension funds and Banks so I
did that for five years and that's when
I first was introduced to the world of
fraud on Wall Street that's when uh
um uh Kidder Peabody blew up there was a
traitor that had some Bonds in in the
desk this is before you know trades were
entered into computer systems you could
hide Bonds in the desk I guess back in
the day but yeah what years was this
this was uh between 1990 and 95. also
Orange County blew up uh I remember the
best salesman in my office was in the
California office I was in the Chicago
branch
and he was selling bonds to Orange
County that blew up when it just rates
roads I remember them yeah you remember
that yeah I do and so that was my first
foray in the fraud a young man I went
back to business school Indiana
University got an MBA in finance then
went to uh Donaldson Lufkin and generat
which was a Investment Bank and it was
known for equity research and I was an
electric utility analyst and I was there
from 97 through 99. and right down the
hall for me where the internet fellows
and they were minting money and that was
when another fraud occurred the.com
fraud and what was going on there was
basically uh the due diligence process
that investment banks used to do was to
like before they brought a company
public they had to have something called
revenues and cash flows
and we were they were they were issuing
companies with highball metrics and you
know we we know how that ended now there
were some companies that did Rise From
the Ashes Amazon being one of them but
that was a lot of corporate fraud that
led to other frauds like Worldcom uh
Enron what have you so that was the era
of corporate fraud and I saw that I only
spent two years at dlj and then I went
up to Boston to a firm called
Independence Investments uh to be a
technology analyst and because of what I
saw going on in the halls of dlj I knew
that it was going to end badly uh
steered my firm the best I could as a
young analyst through that debacle and
parlayed that into a job at BlackRock as
a portfolio manager in 2002. and uh
spent 10 years there raising assets we
started off with 2 billion through
performance and asset Gathering we grew
it so we had a good track record and we
also uh steered our fund through the
great financial crisis which was another
fraud I saw
and in these frauds there's always a
refrain in in the internet fraud it was
it's a new paradigm ad
and and you could say that was my first
mass formation psychosis you know people
there were like it's it's different Ed
you can't you got to get on board and
then in the great real estate crisis
home prices never go down right and of
course all you had to do was Google
home price is falling and you know you
saw that 50 years before that they had
fallen and then now the scene that I'm
involved in is tracking ones and zeros
dead not dead disabled not disabled and
the refrain I heard for this I call this
a fraud this is uh a fraud that involves
different silos media a Pharma
government uh regulatory capture so this
is the biggest fraud we've ever seen and
the refrain is safe and effective so
every every fraud error has a refrain
and this is this is the most egregious
fraud I've ever seen in my life and so
how did I figure out those other frauds
pattern recognition following Trends and
so I'm just a guy that uh tries to get
ahead of everybody else that was my job
was to be first can you can you go
through that a little bit more because I
was about to ask you the question and
you said how do I find out a pattern
recognition Trend so
such as what so what do you look for
what numbers do you look for you saw
internet you saw what happened with
mortgages in 08 I think you guys even
were
calling that right when like the whole
big short concept you were also saying
that this season is coming where you
know all these mortgage-backed
Securities they're gonna go get crushed
so what what data do you look for and
what commonalities do you see with how
covet was handled versus the prior three
frauds so what you look for is a a trend
change every markets go up and they go
down so you try to get ahead of the
curve you don't want to be too early
because if you're early you get run over
um you know Michael Berry from The Big
Short was two years early and he almost
got defunded his investors almost bailed
on them but they they held in and he
made phenomenal killing so there's a bit
of timing to this but uh you know what
what you look for is my sweet spots
between perception and reality right so
the herd is perceiving a truth
and the numbers underlying that truth
are starting to change the herd is
perceiving the truth and the underlying
numbers are starting to change correct
and so basically uh you try to capture
when that react when the perception is
going to change to the new reality and
so with this this fraud that I saw from
the get-go it started to seem strange
before the vaccine was introduced in
2020 uh I saw people
um being uh suppressed censorship and
you know I'm one of those I'm an
information junkie so when someone when
someone tells me not to look at
something it's like a moth to a flame
I'm gonna go look so there was all sorts
of inconsistencies especially along the
lines of the treatment protocols that
were coming out we all know now in
hindsight that there was a suppression
of early treatment to make way for the
vaccine and you had to know something
about emergency youth authorization law
which stated that there could be no
emergency use authorization issued if
there are treatments available and
that's why there was a demonization of
ivermectin and hydroxychloroquine which
if you know as far as I'm concerned work
I've done the protocol myself when I got
covered last year and I I had a sore
throat so early on there was just a lot
of discrepancies mask no mask this uh
unified messaging from the global
governments which we here's a pattern
here's a recognition of a pattern when
have you ever seen Global governments in
unison agree on anything prior to 2020
never and all at once same messaging
same phrases same procedures all at once
so that was kind of a clue that
something different was going on here
what a question when is the last time
you've seen all the world governments
countries being on the same page never
never
and so so once you once once you you
know ask that question the answer is no
then you have you can start a whole
series of other questions of exploration
so okay so as you or you're diving in
and you're looking through and I'm
assuming obviously you're not vaccinated
right no I I did not but you know let's
most of my family and loved ones did so
I was telling them not to because I knew
three things right that it was an
experimental vaccine never been tested
on humans I knew that because of my
background on Wall Street I knew that
moderna was a sketchy company before
they got the contract to do this I knew
that most vaccines take seven to ten
years uh
to get safety data before they're
approved and I also intuitively knew the
operation warp speed sounded like an
absolute disaster to me anything warp
speed sounds like safety protocols cut
manufacturing processes rushed it just
sounded like so I said to myself
internally I'm going to wait
and then to my dismay I didn't realize
the propaganda campaign that was going
to be you know implemented upon the
population so the globe so when I saw
everyone around me rushing to get this
thing I was horrified I was like it
hasn't been tested let me let me ask you
a crazy question Tom this goes to you
guys as well if if let's just say the
president went to these insurance
companies and said look we are going to
do this warp speed but to gain the
people's trust you cannot upsell and get
a bigger profit margin you have to sell
this at Cost I don't know if that makes
sense or not so if it's like hey if this
thing's gonna cost you 60 cents the
vaccines sell it at 60 cents not build
the insurance carrier 50 bucks or 100
bucks right you think that would have
made a difference in the carrier saying
well if that's the case and we're not
going to make any money on it we're just
doing this purely out of a world crisis
to take care of them I think we need six
more months I think we need three more
months I think we need nine more months
because there is no benefit here it's
just purely we're doing it because it's
a problem that we have and the downside
is Big because if if any of these things
have any side effects we're going to be
you know dealing with a lawsuit you
think that would have made any kind of a
difference
yeah are you talking about insurance
companies at the drug company the drug
companies who I'm talking about if they
would have gone to Pfizer modern and
said you have to sell this at cost you
cannot make a profit off of it you know
what that might have changed their
internal uh you know Net Present Value
calculations for sure you know what I'm
asking yeah I'm the person I'm like
listen you want to do this no problem
you can't capitalize off this crisis and
make billions of dollars if you're
willing to sell the only companies I
will work with to distribute this drug
this vaccine is those who do it at cost
if you do it at Cost no problem if not
We're not gonna be doing this that might
that might have changed that might have
changed things here's a statistic that
everyone needs to know so it took
decades and decades for Pfizer to get to
40 billion in revenues before covet
after covet in one year 90 billion wow
go deeper on those numbers by the way
when you say when the company was
founded yeah from when it was founded to
you know right before covet it took
decades to get to 40 plus billion pull
up when Pfizer Pfizer was started and
then Rob since covid they've 40 to 90
billion one year in one year they they
went to 90 billion in revenues now I did
some back of the envelope math
prior to you get to go you got to go
back to 2021. the idea was we were not
decades by the way it's not decades it's
1849. okay long time 60 years how many
children years yeah go ahead you were
sane
um so uh
I did some back of the envelope math in
2021 you have to go back to when we were
at the fever pitch of Terror and fear if
you remember correctly they were talking
about quarterly boosters odd infant item
forever with vaccine passports and you
had to get your papers checked this is
this is back in 21. so I did some back
of the envelope math that that if that
had occurred and this had been carried
out and Pfizer got half of the global
share of the vaccine and I assumed 5
billion people would be vaccinated 2
billion would either not or abstain and
they uh and they and I looked at what
they were charging for the vaccine
quarterly boosters that would have
gotten them about 390 billion in
revenues
that was that was that was where they
wanted to take this and that'd be bigger
than Apple's revenue streams
yeah last year 2022 if you just show
what I just text she's 100 billion
dollars 2022 is what they did so okay so
a part of it that made guys like you
skeptical was warp speed that just
doesn't sound right so name Bad Name all
the countries are united on the same
page on doing this fear levels are high
mainstream media High censorship you
can't argue against it these are way too
many red flags that you're looking at
yeah so to to those who are overly
skeptical and they don't trust somebody
forcing them to do something that
doesn't naturally work well with them
okay so the rule Breakers you know guys
like you Berry or whoever just some of
the guys are like yeah I don't know if
I'm buying into this thing you're
forcing me to do it I need someone tell
I need some more data what happened
recently when you started looking at the
death rates because I'm in the Life
Insurance space I've been in it for 22
years right so you know I see cost of
insurance I see actually we sit there
and we talk to carriers while covet was
going on and they would tell us the data
here's what we're seeing here's what
we're seeing here's what we're seeing
one of the things you talked about
is the percentages which uh uh you know
overwhelming data from the insurance
industry confirms the dangers of
covid-19 injections according to Dao in
his interview with uh Jones he quoted
specific numbers from multiple major
insurance companies that point toward
massive increased debts debt claims Unum
Insurance Q4 death claim versus 2019 up
36 percent Lincoln National up 57
Prudential up 41 Renaissance group of
America up 21 Hartford up to 32 percent
MetLife up 24. uh aegon 24 a Dutch
insurance company whom I used to be a
part of that company plus 57 percent and
Q3 in Q Q4 in Q3 they saw an increase of
258 percent in claims that's aegon these
numbers are shocking according to Dallas
so
these numbers if you can explain to the
audience what does this mean when you
see this and and from there on what did
you start investigating right so that
you're gonna go back that was in the
first quarter of 2022 okay and we were
we were starting you know we had already
uh had already gone kind of viral and I
got a team assembled around me Josh
Sterling was a former
um sell side Analyst at Sanford
Bernstein for seven years he was number
one ranked Institutional Investor so he
basically knew what he was talking about
he helped me analyze these results and
what we decided to do was look at group
Life policies specifically because whole
life as you know from insurance uh it's
uh it's Byzantine accounting so group
life is shorter duration contract so we
knew losses would show up there
immediately and they did
um so that was early days and uh the
numbers were astounding because
basically the the group life folks
hadn't priced the policies correctly and
why is that because in 2021 there was a
mixture from old to Young in terms of
excess deaths 2020 was all about old
people dying and that's okay for
insurance companies because a lot of
already paid in they're not on group
Life policies anymore because they're
retired doesn't matter but something
very striking happened in 2021 and
that's when we really started you know
thinking we were 100 right that the
vaccine was doing something so the big
mix shift from old to Young was a big
tell for us covet wasn't killing young
people in 2020 what was killing people
in 2021 we we obviously think it's the
vaccines and the data keeps rolling in
we've got all 22 in and it's it's not
looking good and since since those
numbers that you uh you spoke about the
Society of actuaries as you know
collated all the numbers from the group
life industry they do a survey eighty
percent of the revenues are covered and
they verified our numbers uh in August
of 2022 with the report that they put
out table 5.7 is the big table and it's
it's claims it's not dollars it's just
claims and right now if you were to look
at the group life calls see results this
quarter
they're not that bad because they've
priced it up they've repriced everything
so that the losses aren't occurring
because they're just raising prices but
the claims the number of the units the
deaths is still up and what we saw in uh
2021 was alarming one of the biggest
things that I think is a Smoking Gun is
what happened to the Millennials in the
third quarter of 2021. in the group life
policyholders their excess mortality
prior to that in the spring was running
around 30 percent now you got to
remember 10 percent as stated by Scott
Davis and at one America is a once in a
200 year flood for this age group 25
through 44.
um and he was seen 40 percent uh 40
percent is off the charts but in the
third quarter of 2021 in table 5.7 their
excess mortality rose up to 84 percent
84 and then it's it's come down since
then which is good news but it's still
running around 23 percent and I uh a
whistleblower mine at an insurance
company who has insight to the Society
of actuary numbers just leaked to me
we're re-accelerating this you know in
the fourth quarter 2022 so it's not good
news
but for me
that this Spike to 84 percent was it was
what I call an event what was that event
well it was called mandates and mass
vaccination program this is a group of
people that aren't supposed to die and
especially group life policyholders as
you know Patrick
uh the these folks are the the elite
elite they work at Fortune 500 companies
mid-sized companies and they have access
to the best health care so why would all
of a sudden they die in in in in a very
temporal Spike like that we're we're
assuming it's the mandates in the
vaccines I've heard the naysayers tell
me edit suicides so there was a suicide
pact in the third quarter 21. yeah
doubtful right
um was there uh and now I'm also told
well drug overdoses well to get a group
life claim you have to be employed with
the company I don't know too many
Fentanyl and heroin users at Fortune 500
companies that keep their jobs for long
so there wasn't a mass you know
overdosing situation and then the third
one that I heard was that they missed
their cancer screening treatment or
appointments I'm 56 I haven't had a
cancer screening in my life certainly
young people aren't going to cancer no I
have a question it's
easy to appreciate what you're doing
because you're a numbers guy you're a
data guy you know so it's what do they
say the numbers don't lie the math
doesn't lie so you can totally
appreciate that I'm looking at your book
by the way which is ironically is an
actual book not according to chat PPT
respect but I'm looking at it and I'm
noticing the the title of your book
Cause unknown is in air quotes and
quotes it was that intentional for a
reason because based on your data I
think you do know the cause would you
kind of in layman's term break that down
yeah no so we tongue-in-cheek put it in
quotes on purpose because
um this book uh was pitched to me by uh
Gavin de Becker Aroma afterward and
Bobby Kennedy uh they wanted me to
um talk about sudden athletic deaths and
I said you know that that's a good idea
but that's mostly anecdotal I'm a dad so
we married the two together so we want
to show we wanted to put a lot of human
faces on this
um this this is tragic when athletes die
especially young athletes it's tragic
any deaths tragic but especially Young
Folks and that's uh that's what's
occurring and the anecdotal evidence of
the sudden athletic deaths is is pretty
alarming
um
there was a study done uh the Los
Angeles study in 2006 a bunch of guys in
Switzerland did this they tried to
figure out what was the incidence of
sudden athletic death and they found
1101 such cases under age 35 where it
occurred on the field or right
thereafter after the field 1101 over 38
years is 29 per year so that's kind of
the Baseline since uh starting uh in
2021 it's exploded we'd be lucky to have
a month with just 29 sudden athletic
deaths we've had months with 90.
the December of 2021 was 90. so and in
my book my book's not exhaustive there's
just there's hundreds and hundreds of
these cases mostly local news stories so
just based on my anecdotal evidence
that's a tenfold increase
and the case studies in your book how
many exact examples you put in your book
and then how many of them are athletes
uh yeah I I can't remember the exact
number but there's hundreds and then we
put a bunch in the back it's just
there's just so many there's hundreds
and hundreds yeah so from 29 a year
to 29 worst case a month with a high of
90 in a month
I'm not even sure if it's 90 that was as
the writing of the book it could have
gotten it could it could it could be
higher in certain months so so what are
people saying when you're asking them
they're saying the collapses are
happening because of what like you
remember the interview the the Daryl
Hamilton is it Daryl Hamlet yes
she said I would I I'd like it was like
a seven second pause and then you can
tell they edited the video and Michael
Strahan asked the question but I can
tell you they did not put it in there I
don't know if you saw this reaction or
not I saw it yeah so you know do you
have that video you know because you you
it seems like you I mean
Strahan is asking a question that
everybody is going to be asking it's not
like he's asking a question that's like
a genius question it's a question the
world is waiting for a people want the
right question to be asked can you go to
the part where the questions being asked
just fast forward to the part where the
questions being asked yeah there you go
I think it's about to be asked if you
want to press put the audio to the right
all the way to the right yeah there you
go could run circles around me right now
how did Doctor describe what happened to
you
um
that's something I want to stay away
from I know from my experience so so
here's my question that's something I
want to stay away from and by the way
kudos to ABCs for showing the seven
second pause because ABC's could have
cut that seven second pause and just not
answer but they put the video out there
and they even put that thought out there
which
maybe ABC yurga wouldn't even put the
answer in the question now we don't need
to put that because it's going to create
a lot of what you know skepticism and
guys like us may be talking about it it
amplifies but here's here's the question
what was the question the question was
what what did the doctors tell you about
this has anybody spoken to the doctor
that was handling him to ask what he
said to him and is that doctor gonna say
this is a private client
patient that had a relationship that I
can because of HIPAA regulations but uh
yeah I mean so so what are people saying
if this number one from 29 a year to 29
a month to a high of 90 plus more than
29 a month he says we're lucky to have
only two that's what I'm saying 29 is
the worst month like yeah so what are
they saying the causes for this well
recently uh Yahoo news and Bloomberg
have the good news is this was being
this subject was completely ignored this
this death in young people but recently
in the last couple weeks it had to at
least acknowledge it exists Bloomberg
said yes young people are dying but it's
not the vaccines that was their headline
and then Yahoo news put out a similar
headline and then I read the Yahoo news
and they've described the deaths again
they named some unknown expert we talked
to some experts and they said that covid
is causing
the immune system of uh healthy young
people to go Haywire because it's so
strong so your strong immune system as a
young person is now deadly because of
covid you can't make this up there
there's there's no study they just say
it this is the article you were talking
about from Bloomberg more Young
Americans are dying but not from
vaccines the increase started well
before covid-19 shots according to
mortality data in us plateaued since if
you can zoom out move up a little bit
can we read the rest of the article or
you have to uh
uh uh can you zoom in or no
okay there you go go a little lower a
little lower so no the other way so I
can read the top yeah keep going keep
going keep going okay so for most people
on the field Cardiac Arrest of Buffalo
Bill safety tomorrow Hamlin January
second one was a frightening a potential
energy followed by Mercy not looking as
happy ending uh vocal minority those
seized and it's as perpetu uh uh uh
perpeted what is that word where are you
purported purported evidence of the
terrible Tola mRNA covid-19 vaccines
have exacted on otherwise healthy Young
Americans the medical establishment and
the mainstream media have generally
dismissed such concerns the medical
establishment well that's the problem uh
Bloomberg to write the word
establishment and the mainstream media
you're assuming that some people trust
the medical establishment of an insta
media generally dismiss such concerns
out of hand but whenever I hear them I
ask myself I wonder if there's any
evidence of that in mortality data so go
up let's see if their argument is going
to get stronger
um so U.S mortality the statistics
derived from death certificates filled
by uh Physicians and medical examiners
collected from state and local public
health agencies by Center Disease
Control and provincial National Center
interns are available online to anyone
on a computer they used to be updated
only annually but during the pandemic
the CDC began releasing Provisions
numbers as recently takes a little while
to learn how to okay keep going they're
not giving an answer on the data here so
you know uh uh go zoom into that one
with mortality data shows that first of
all something has been killing American
young people and sharply Rising numbers
lately the 2020 mortality rate from 15
to 34 was the highest since 73 for those
25 to 34. it's the high since 1950.
death per 100 000 population 15 to okay
that sharp right there yeah good look
and by the way during the lockdown can
you speak to this you know I was reading
this during the lockdown they also
failed to point out that auto accident
deaths were way down because of because
millions and billions of Miles were not
being driven by that that cohort and so
therefore those deaths were down simply
because you're not driving a car and yet
the total number was up but you're
talking about X excess mortality right
excess mortality can you how where would
the like the reduction in Auto that's
down where would that show up is that in
the base number not the excess number it
would be it would be in the total number
it would detract from excess deaths so
whatever's going on is access to what
would be down from made up for the Auto
Action yeah normal correct years and
years of date Decades of data on auto
deaths which are down it makes up for
that and more yeah you know in my book I
talk about something else that's
interesting regarding lockdown so
there's a Smoking Gun in the UK data
that we found found where
um
once the vaccines were introduced age
all age groups except 1 through 14
started Having excess deaths 1 through
14 age group their vaccines are
introduced later around November of
2021.
excess mortality for that age group was
coming down during the lockdowns because
the largest single cause of death in
that age cohort is accidental so less
activity so their excess mortality was
coming down down down and even even when
the lockdowns
came off in the spring in the UK their
excess mortality kept coming down then
in November of 2021 it started going
back up for age group 1 through 14
that's when the vaccine was introduced
in the UK it's no longer I think being
offered for kids in it I think they just
suspended boosters for under 50 as well
in the UK or they're no longer promoting
it I have a question on the lockdowns
that Tom was talking about so
it's almost like accountability and
which one is worse and let me frame this
so
get the covid vaccine because that'll
protect you and save your life okay
that's option one or option two is all
right you're locked down and because
you're in the house even we had this
conversation with Neil deGrasse Tyson
and because you're on lockdown so people
are drinking more they're taking more
opioids fentanyl you're saying that
they're you're drinking more missing
cancer screenings
I guess my question is well what's worse
right so you're mandating vaccines
so and then you know cause unknown air
quotes or you're forcing people to stay
home and now they're resorting to not
taking care of their health not working
out drinking drugs alcohol
at the end of the day it seems like a
recipe for disaster that there's going
to be deaths either way so ultimately
you know we have to pay the price as
Americans for this resounding number of
deaths whether it's from the vaccine or
whether it's from lockdowns do you see
my question and I'm sure in 2020 there
were some people that drank too much or
you know had some bad habits but the the
predominance of death excess deaths in
2020 was old people that's in the
numbers because I was pre-vaccine
pre-vac I think it's important to point
that out and that's when most of the
lockdowns occurred they kind of we
weren't really locked down in 2021
depending on what states you were in
yeah for the most part here in Free
State of Florida no but but here's
something uh shocking so uh
between so the mixture from Ulta young
is in the numbers so from 2020 to 2021
40 000 Millennials died in 2020
excessively sixty thousand in 2021. so
they added say that again in 2020 40 000
Millennials died excessively according
to CDC numbers
um and then in 2021 it was sixty
thousand what is the word excessively
that means above and beyond the normal
the normal expected rate and so that's a
50 increase and then the Gen X didn't
fare much better that ninety four
thousand gen xers died excessively in
2020.
120 000 in 21 whereas old people were in
2021 went the other way there were less
so there was this what we call on Wall
Street a mix shift and I would say it's
an adverse makeshift it's a very weird
data to go that way yeah it's very weird
because the virus morph that it only
start to attack younger folks that are
employed so so then I so then I will
come back and I will tell you I would
say look the elders who got the vaccine
more older people or Millennials and gen
X's I would say elders
were elderly was more fearful of the
vaccine so like in my family uh of covet
yeah more more fearful of covet yeah so
my dad got the vaccine two shots and he
got the three boosters my dad he's 80
years old about to be 81 in uh next
month Nanny got the vaccine and the uh
boosters right to them it was like What
if this what if that what if there's
people coming to the house they were
having called my dad had covet and
pneumonia at the same time at 79 years
old I was scared that he was going
through it so
that data you're saying why would
the excessive number go higher for
Millennials and Gen X is did they get
vaccines more than the elderly did uh
they they well they got the vaccines in
21 through mandates
so there was no vaccine in 2020.
right so the mix shift for excess deaths
occurred in the young folks in 2021.
no I just started getting the vaccine
and then this one cohort goes up 50 the
next cohort goes up 33 correct
and why wouldn't older people's numbers
that's what I'm asking why wouldn't
there because they also took the back
well because there was a pull forward
effect we took out a lot of the uh the
weak older people with uh some of the um
the unfortunate protocols that went down
in the early days I mean they died
already they died already because there
was a pull forward effect and what so
you've seen the numbers in 2021 old
people excess deaths coming down because
we we got we took all the weak old
people were taken out by covet and or
bad treatment in 2020. their numbers
came down excessively because we just
took out a whole bunch of people but
there have been since vaccinations keep
rolling they started to go back up again
well let me ask you do you remember when
they showed uh Rob if he can find this
data where they showed which uh uh uh
cohort got the vaccine the most uh those
without a high school those without a
college degree College dropouts those
with a bachelor's degree mba's PhD I
don't know if you remember this yeah it
showed that mbas was were the least mbas
uh degree was the highest bachelor's
degree was the highest they were getting
the vaccine and I think High School
dropouts or college dropouts were the
lowest second lowest after NBA so when
you do think about Millennials Gen X Gen
Y uh Boomers which one of them got the
highest percentage of uh in seniors
which one got the highest percentage of
the vaccine uh I haven't done that data
because we don't have vaccine we don't
we don't have that really
as granular as we would like or rather
than 70 U.S over the bachelor's degree
had been vaccinated or planning to get
vaccinated compared to just half to 53
percent less education in other words a
college degree is associated with a 43
increase and likelihood that someone
plans to get the vaccine the difference
by education level is larger than
difference in the willingness to get
vaccinated whites and blacks 32 percent
the difference between interesting
Latinos three percent so you you saw
almost those people that are getting a
bachelor degree they're following the
system right correct can you see if you
can find the data which generation got
the most vaccine while he's doing that
Tom's gonna ask a question so yeah there
are some whistleblowers that came out
that talked about hospitals uh assigning
causation to Deaths and whistleblowers
came out saying you know I've I had an
elderly person who stroked and got
classified as covid because the hospital
was looking to get the combat pay you
know those payments from the federal
government you're looking at total
deaths which nor normalizes all that out
of why it's causation you're looking at
Mass cohorts not mass cohorts the the
mass of numbers and the cohort saying
look it's up which completely normalizes
out all of the BS and it's not BS that's
what it is committing frauds yeah to get
the combat pay from the federal
government yes yes so we we focus on the
what we call the metadata the ones and
zeros because we knew that yep as you go
down into the data streams there'd be
fraud so we're just counting the you
can't hide the one the the one versus
the zero you can't hide the disabled
versus the undisabled so we stay up
there we're starting to go down deeper
we're doing a vaccine damage project
right now my team
um but yeah that's what we have is
irrefutable there's just ones and zeros
and the number and and because it was a
mass vaccination program and it was
Global these numbers that we're seeing
occur in all different Western countries
and for me The Smoking Gun is the group
life folks this is height of actuary
numbers and then we've yet to talk about
the disability numbers that we've gotten
from the U.S Bureau of Labor Statistics
yeah so the point I was I was getting to
for everybody listening and was to
confirm that says hey a lot of people
talk about all the things who died of
covet didn't die of covet but when you
step back and we're looking at total
deaths over time at the time vaccines
are introduced for oh now it's okay for
under 14. now it's okay for under six
you're tracking that as that came like a
wave correct and the elderly the culling
of the herd with the elderly that was
the one where people were remuted in
their attempt to say it but they were
pointing out saying hey look this is far
worse than regular flu and regular flu
will take out an obese career smoker on
a regular flu season this is worse than
that and that was the elderly culling of
the herd yeah and and let's not forget
uh different protocols that probably
didn't help like REM Des movere
ventilation has now been proven to be
quite deadly for this disease unless not
also forget
um I lost my train of thought but I'll
come back to it
yeah but but going back to it I'm really
trying to find out what percentage
uh which generation got the vaccine the
most we can come back to this you know
you know what I want you to go to
Rob uh we were looking at a number
earlier how many vaccinations have been
given so far in the last two and a half
years as of October of 2022 I believe
the number was 12 and a half billion so
we're shy of 15 billion vaccines given
in Utah
in U.S this is from statista which you
know credible Source purely data number
of covenanting vaccine doses
administered in the U.S as of February
23rd two weeks old and if you can zoom
in on the numbers Pfizer number one
Pfizer is number one at 400 million uh
then their booster is number two at 34
million moderna's number two number two
when it comes down to the main 251
million their boosters at 19-4 Johnson
and Johnson obviously we know what
happened to them 18.9 million and he got
a couple other guys that are there so
give it give or take on this what's that
650 80 700 million just in the US okay
700 million just in the US I think the
number is 67 percent 66 or 67 percent of
Americans are vaccinated if I if I
remember that statistic uh correctly I
saw 66 or 67 Americans are vaccinated so
how much of this do you believe as a
data person this is either this is going
to be opinion or if you have any kind of
data to prove it you know it'd be great
how much it is do you think is you know
when when I was in a relationship and I
was an 18 year old kid or 22 year old
kid and I'm dating somebody and I was
see serious relationship my friends
wanted me to be single those who were
single wanted me to be single right okay
I'm kind of like dude you know you gotta
you gotta get a girl it's great when
you're in a relationship like nah bro
you want to be single you don't have to
answer to anybody I'm like dude it's
fine you know it's like do you come to
the party they're asking about you okay
great then you want to be single then
when you're single uh married couples
want you to get married it's okay dude
let me tell you man life is better when
you're married you don't have to worry
about it and run around all over the
you're like dude okay let me get married
and you're married like dude it's single
people so then it's like no bro you're
married but divorce is the way to be you
got to join the divorce party and go you
know and you know we were reading a
statistic about a wife talking about why
you know statistics and Maui how it is
you know
so you know say hey you got to get
divorced man it's really cool when
you're divorced because now you have
money and you can do this and imagine
all those young girls like guys with
money and success and the game is a
different y'all I want to be divorced
how much of this with covet back people
who got the vaccination it's like no
join my Camp because God forbid if I'm
wrong
for having taken a vaccine purely by
fear how much of it is people just want
to defend their decision that they made
the right decision and they don't want
to be proven that they were wrong oh
it's huge I saw this on Wall Street all
the time uh it's you know my ethics
professor said something that stuck in
my head from business school he said you
can't rationalize facts to someone whose
position is based on emotion so a lot of
people took this out of fear which is an
emotion and then they convinced others
to join them on the ride and now data is
coming out that they may have been wrong
and ego is a big part of what I saw in
Wall Street I saw people ride stocks
down to zero where you know news flow
was coming out that it was bad and
they'd keep buying all the way down
because they couldn't admit they're
wrong this phenomenon is now being
repeated on a national global scale with
this vaccine people just don't want to
admit they're wrong and it's the the
problem is this isn't money this is like
potentially your health so yeah I view
the vaccine now trade right you're
either along the vaccine or short the
vaccine if you're long it
um you you continue to get boosters
because if you took it and now you're
hesitant that's great don't take take it
but if you continue to get boosters
that's like buying a stock on its way to
zero and if you're if you and if you've
if you if you didn't take the vaccine
you're on I think the right side of the
trade so it's a trade in my mind and
what was the original thesis of the
trade it prevented you from getting
coveted and transmitting we both know
those are lies so the thesis is
unwinding as we roll through time so
people who keep defending this are now
defending it based upon what I call
marketing scheme from Pfizer and modern
which says it reduces your chance of
being seriously hospitalized there's no
there's no paper on that you know
there's no data you know how they say
like don't throw good money after bad
correct
um so let's say you're the 70 plus crowd
you're like listen I'm I'm old I'm I'm
gonna do what I got to do to protect my
health or if you have pre-existing
conditions but what would your mass
message be for the 20 30 40 somethings
the millennial crowd even
you know do they keep riding the stock
all the way down because I'm saying for
people that have gotten the vaccine is
it just stop it with the boosters
you know I get it you did it but here's
what you should do moving forward and a
lot a lot of people a lot of people were
forced to do it a lot of people didn't
want to do it but they did it and
there's a big what I call marginal
mental of people that weren't that
enthusiastic about this those are the
people I'm trying to reach there's the
hardcore covidians who aren't going to
change their mind they're going to get
jab jab jab good luck to them covidians
I call them Branch covidians it's a
religion it's a religion in many ways to
a lot a lot of these folks tribal
identity
um they did a lot of virtue signaling
yeah I mean when it comes to to play you
know in line two when it comes to blame
okay there you go you just found the
goat is that the one good for you rob
let me let me zoom in a little bit thank
you for looking forward nominal Which
percentage of people in each age range
received vaccine the most 65 plus is the
highest okay and by the what's the
difference between oh at least one is
the pink fully is the navy blue okay 65
is the highest and it's 50 this makes
sense to me uh scroll down so we see
what the the bottom line 25 to 49. is
that zero to 100 at the bottom yeah and
the light pink okay extending to the
right is all those is this American or
is this worldwide
this this I'm assuming this is going to
be us because it's going to be this is
USA fact so does that mean almost 90
plus percent of 65 plus got
the Jab and remember with the refrain
getting back to your top at the
marketing you were just talking about
the refrain safe and effective safe and
effective get the elders first and Cuomo
on TV let's protect people in the
retirement homes that's what drove that
right well they had they got uh first
write a refusal and then you started
seeing it's a hundred percent 99 you go
a little lower 90. I don't think
I think it was let's protect them and so
you had the nation's children and
grandchildren lobbying Grandma and
Grandpa to get get it you're first
because you're the most vulnerable
grandma go get it watch this here white
is the
second lowest
blacks are the lowest to get the vaccine
then the highest is American Indian
Alaskan native Asian is second native
Hawaiian
specifically Maui it's it's a
Pacific Islanders the third and then you
got Hispanics fourth multiple other
then you got whites and blacks go Lord
let's see what other data you see here
okay that's that's it that's what you
got very interesting right there well I
mean that that I'd be curious to know if
you go to California what's the
California number vaccinated California
is what 85.74
85 percent
that that that is insane to me go to New
York see what New York is left left of
ma there you uh right there yeah it's
what 93 oh my goodness what about
Florida yeah Florida's
61 is that 61 or 81 percent 81 okay so
that's seniors go to Texas
75 percent go to Illinois
uh what is that 78 go to Oregon yeah
because outside of Chicago path it's 82.
interesting Florida's 81 seniors go to
Connecticut Connecticut is a hardcore
you know
go to Alabama go to Mississippi go down
there
Alabama is 64 percent
or you have a higher 600
African-Americans which showed up on the
other chart 61 64 hmm huh go to Utah
just out of curiosity Utah 74 yeah in
Hawaii or for our friend Ed
99 yeah I I I live you guys are killing
it out there I live in a strange State a
lot of people got probably the wrong
phrase yeah by the way and somebody just
commented somebody just commented right
now Raul or PESA did a Super Chat he
says it's not necessarily that those
with a bachelor's degree are following
the system as a student I was forced
yeah to take the vaccine before I could
continue with my classes as at undergrad
level maybe grad students were forced as
well interesting no these mandates are
still going on in U.S colleges I I Notre
Dame still yeah Notre Dame is one of the
most egregious uh policies right now and
I'm just horrified I'm not going to give
them a dime until uh well can't get into
the United States here we go cannot play
in a tennis tournament 2.0
yeah you you know yes uh Sunday I'm at
the park and I'm talking to a friend
Jeremy and I said hey would you ever uh
uh be okay with your son serve in the
military says I would love for my son so
to serve the military one day and
protect this country but I can't I said
why not he said because they're going to
force him to take the vaccine I say your
reasoning is purely vaccine related says
yes he says how many vaccines did you
take I told him I took 11 on the first
week when you go into the military and
then we also had to take the anthrax we
had to take all this other stuff that's
military property
I wonder how many parents are going to
be turned like Tom your kids going to
school they have to take the vaccine to
go to school
uh no not right now
right certain schools no no no no not
high school college if she chooses to go
to a certain college she has to take the
vaccine well we're going to see what
those mandates look like but we're we're
quietly looking at that sort of stuff as
we my daughter's a junior took the SATs
so this fall all the packets go in right
November 1st and part of our evaluation
process is is it an is it mandate or is
it optional or is it preferred you're
looking at that and you guys are
seriously considering that as you have
to yeah man that is pretty wild as a
parent you have to sit there and say you
know I'd love my kid to go to such and
such college but they mandate vaccines
you know what because of that we're not
going to go there I mean a lot of
parents are gonna have to make these
decisions and at 83 000 a year national
average for most uh private and fully
established state universities that's
the average what's the number 83 000
that's room board travel that's a
national average the the tuition is
right around 60 but then you have about
15 to 7 team for a dorm and meal card
and books and all lab fees so for 83 000
a year
I have to pay that to increase the
mortality rate of my daughter sorry yeah
that's the insanity that we're under one
stat I'd love to share with all with the
audiences in uh between March of 21 and
Feb of 22 when we first started doing
this 60 000 Millennials excessively died
in the Vietnam War uh 58 000 soldiers
died over 12 years so in one year 60 000
Millennials disappeared one was due to
the Viet Cong and the other was due to a
needle I think
um
what do you think the refrain not what
do you think what are you observing
their friend because safe and effective
was a refrain and I'll go back and I'll
share with people how this works because
I have to agree with you about fraud so
I'm going to ask a question at the end
of this statement
I was part of a venture funded company
in year 2000 and we were out trying to
raise money and we had uh we were our
product was sold as a subscription you
know for money that paid operating cost
and so we were not eyeballs or what uh
back in the day was called vanity stats
right
um
and as a investor and coming from Wall
Street you know what that is what was
happening at that time is
The Venture Capital Community was openly
saying listen right now we've got you
know a lot of dot-coms they were simply
called dot coms at the time and we got
to get out and there's one or two ways
to do it one is greater Fool's theory
that uh another VC marks up the
valuation and comes in
the second and so that positions it
favorably
but that's just marking up your
investment the way they got out was
through IPOs what happens at the IPOs is
there would be some shares that we
restricted that couldn't be sold but in
many cases the VCS got out with the
public offering so in other words the
Venture Capital Community knew that
these dot coms had structural issues but
there is this the bankers were getting
banking fees they were in favor of the
IPOs The Venture Capital was in favor of
transferring all their risk to the
public market and then getting the
return on what they had and then maybe
they had some of the that was left there
and the refrain that I heard over and
over again hey the rules have changed
it's different business now the rules
have changed and I would ask what rules
which rules have changed are people just
going to be buying online so you're
taking retail costs out of brick and
mortar but the refrain back then I
remember was the rules have changed but
I was looking at it and I was kind of
horrified because I said all the VCS are
doing is getting out to the next round
and this time it it's the public market
so now they're out so the.com crash that
happened on Wall Street after they went
public but they got out and you know who
they had air cover from
the money that's invested by the VCS you
know it comes from
Michigan public employees
Sovereign wealth funds
there is a ton of people that put money
into the VC funds that wanted to get out
so there was a whole group below the
surface you're nodding that they wanted
yeah they wanted to get out so they were
in favor get the IPO out get it to the
public market then the VC got to return
but more importantly Michigan public
employees got their money back uh Yale
Yale med school endowment got their
money back uh major
um family offices got their money back
do you see what I mean and then the.com
crashed on the retail investor yeah
y'all the last person to hold the bag is
always retail it's called a liquidity
event that the the VC's got their
liquidity event at the expense of the
retail investing public so that was a
fraud and that's what I heard that so
other people I wanted to amplify what
what Ed was saying at the beginning
where he said he's seen multiple frauds
in his life I saw that one what is the
refrain right now as we move into
chapter two or three of this pandemic in
covet originally it was safe and
effective get the elderly I remember
that what is it right now what's is
there a refrain now or is this we're in
the Fallout phase well we're in
narrative uh spin control right now so I
see different narratives emerging one of
them is oh you know yes we were wrong
but we didn't we we we were flying by
the seat of our pants and we were doing
the best we could who do you hear that
from who's actually that that that's I
think the Atlantic uh which is kind of
the mouthpiece of the establishment
wrote an article on that recently
talking about masks that said hey n95s
didn't even work right and so oh so Mass
didn't work if the n95 didn't work
forget about the bandanas and all the
cheap masks nothing works the Atlantic
just put out an article recently said
yes the experts failed miserably but you
still need to trust us
we I
these folks seem to have no
self-awareness I just sent you an
article pull that up if you can I like
my alcoholic Uncle slapping my aunt
crying in front of my cousins and then
saying I'm really sorry I did this but
trust me I won't happen again next week
until it does yeah exactly that's the
sorry to hear about your family problems
by the way so uh here's a here's an
article Tom top 25 best vaccine optional
colleges in the U.S number one U.S Naval
Academy number two is look what number
two is UNC interesting isn't that where
a lot of the data came from uh I believe
they did a lot of gain of function
research as well
you're probably going to see all the
academies you're going to see Annapolis
you're gonna see Colorado Springs
Hillsville College Michigan Marines
Davidson mandated uh in the middle
University of Florida just West Point
wait what
was there U of f was in there yeah
absolutely number nine is University of
Florida keep going I know that well you
know why because the university may want
to do it one way but the funder
you know
well it's also Santa
University of Florida is not private
Georgia Tech Georgia Tech you'll
probably put Florida State University
Austin UT Georgia from Wisconsin okay uh
Madison Ohio State Ohio State University
optional okay North Carolina State Rally
Florida State University yeah there yeah
also gets money from Tallahassee by the
way in Tallahassee uh Oberlin College
government Rhode Island Grove City
Southern Methodist SMU good for them
Purdue Texas
okay Indiana yeah so there is options
where they're allowing the kids and the
parents to make a decision no Ivy League
schools huh no the The Ivy Leagues are
still on board yeah and why do you think
that is why are the ivy league so on
board with all this I I you know it's
it's it's it's tribalism I think it's
like they were all in and they're not
you know I don't think Ivy Leaguers like
to admit they're wrong when I was on
Wall Street uh you know I didn't get a
Harvard MBA but I met a lot of Harvard
mbas a lot of them are smart good people
but a lot of them also have egos and
never admit they're wrong even when
they're wrong they'll say Ed you were
right for the wrong reasons
well I just agree to disagree how about
that so so let's transition into the
next you won the game on fumble so you
didn't really win it you didn't win it
with offensive prowess it was fumbles
correct
go to page six to ten minutes about uh
covet experts if you can do that okay uh
this is a New York Post story I'll read
this yeah I thought this was an
interesting uh article
um number one uh 10 myths told by covet
experts and now debunked number one
misinformation number one natural
immunity offers little protection
compared to vaccinated immunity a Lancet
study looked at 65 major studies in 19
countries on natural immunity the
researchers concluded that natural
immunity was at least as effective as
the primary covid vaccine series
information number two can we stop right
there yeah Lance set that's a respected
medical journal so this is somebody
stepping out of line is that correct yes
they put out a lot of misinformation
during covet so they're going to have to
re-establish their credibility I'm sorry
to interrupt you Pat but I saw this
earlier and it's important what you just
said though like did you hear what he
said yeah they put out a lot of
misinformation during covid so now
they're trying to clean up correct some
of their own misinformation that they
put up so good for them at least we're
doing it you know misinformation number
two masks prevent covet transmission
Cochrane reviews are considered the most
authoritative independent researcher
independent assessment of the evidence
of in medicine and one published last
month I highly respected Oxford research
team found that masks had no significant
impact on Cova transmission that's
it's pretty wild to think about all the
fights on planes you know the discomfort
put it on raise it cover your nose all
those you know issues you would have on
flight n95 means
nah 95 chance you get it anyway
Tom you're on fire today with your jokes
oh my God I mean he's trying out to uh
be a comedian
he spent a little too much time with
Crowder yesterday this is what happens
misinformation number three and three
Eddies of coffee schools closures reduce
covet transmission the CDC ignored the
European experience of keeping schools
open most without masks mandates
transmission rates were no different
evidence by studies conducted in Spain
and Sweden okay number four
myocarditis Tom from the vaccine is less
common than from the infection Public
Health officials downplayed concerns
about vaccine included myocarditis or
inflammation of the heart muscle we now
know that myocarditis is 6 to 28 times
more common after covet vaccine than
After The Infection among 16 to 24 year
old males which is kind of this one of
the things you're talking about right
this data here yep number five young
people benefit from a vaccine booster
boosters reduced hospitalizations in
older high-risk Americans but the
evidence was never there uh that they
lower covert mortality in young and
healthy people
by the way so it did help
in older and high-risk Americans
uh that's what they're saying yeah and
this is a New York Post article right
misinformation number six vaccine
mandates increased vaccination rates
President Biden and other officials
demanded that unvaccinated workers
regardless of their risk or natural
immunity to be fired a recent study from
George Mason University details how
vaccine mandates in nine major U.S
cities had no impact on vaccination
rates they also had no impact on covet
transmission rates George Mason for you
number seven covet originating from the
Wuhan lab as a conspiracy theory this
one we're definitely going to get it
through here in a minute I'll come back
to number seven number eight it was
important to get second vaccine dose
three or four weeks after the first dose
data were clear in the spring of 2021
just months after the vaccine rollout
that spacing the vaccine out by three
months reduced complication rates and
increased immunity spacing out vaccines
would have also saved more lives when
Americans were rationing a limited
vaccine Supply at the height of the
pandemic epidemic number nine data on uh
by uh bivalent vaccine is Crystal Clear
Dr ashisha Jah famously said that
despite the bivalent
vaccine being approved using data from
eight mice to date there has never been
a randomized controlled trial of the
bivalent vaccine I think I think all the
mice got coveted
number 10 one in five people got long
coveted
get long covet the CDC and prevention
Clan the CDC claims that 20 of Covenant
infections can result in Long covet it's
often normal to experience mild fatigue
or weakness for weeks after being sick
and inactive and not eating well calling
these cases long covet is the medical
medicalization of ordinary life I'm
going to go back to seven that was the
supplemental fear right you're gonna get
long coveted if you all get it and I'll
fight it off yeah but you could have
long covet and have other things so it's
like the supplemental theory of that
people that thought they were going to
get natural immunity and that's the new
uh one of the reasons being floated for
sudden death and all these excess deaths
is long coveted interestingly long covet
doesn't have a clinical definition yet
and it explains everything and nothing
all at the same time Pat I know you want
to get to number seven but I think even
after seven we should highlight that
next article which I think is a yeah
accountability I mean obviously it's all
within it so number seven covet
originating from the wuha lab is a
conspiracy theory Google admitted to
suppressing searches of lab League
during the pandemic Dr Francis Collins
head of National Institute of uh Health
claimed and still does he doesn't
believe the virus came from a lab
ultimately overwhelming circumstances
circumstantial evidence points to a
lablic origin the same origin suggested
by Dr Anthony fauci by two very
prominent virologists in January 2020
meeting he assembled at the beginning of
the pandemic so you hear that and then
story comes out
by FBI director Ray acknowledges uh the
bureau uh assessment that covid-19
likely resulted from a lab incident this
is a CNN story folks this is not a fox
or anything else this is a CNN story
okay
so FBI director Christopher acknowledge
and literally that with Fox News at the
FP I believe the covid-19 pandemic was
likely the result of a lab accident in
Wuhan China stating that the origins of
the pandemic are most likely a potential
lab incident in Wuhan the department of
energy low confidence assessment that
covid-19 most likely originated from a
laboratory leak in China underscores a
divide in the US government as the
majority of the intelligence Community
still believes that covet either emerged
naturally in the wild or there's still
too little evidence to make a judgment
one way or another race stated that the
FBI has a team of experts who focus on
the risk of biological threats that come
into the wrong cans including a by
hostile nation state and that the
Chinese government has been doing its
very best to try to thwart and up for
how do you pronounce that word upfuscate
the work here so here's my question for
you when you're hearing the director of
FBI saying this is most likely coming
from Wuhan lab when you're hearing you
know the department of energy this can
not be Stephen Colbert calls out the
department of energy I don't know if you
saw that or not yeah if you got pain
yeah if you got the clip of Stephen
Colbert calling out Department of energy
like dude you're a comedian right
exactly he got pissed off at Jon Stewart
for Jon Stewart saying what do you mean
it didn't come from you know if you can
find this clip his reaction he was not
happy about the department of energy
that's also the same Stephen Colbert who
literally had syringed dancers that was
doing the light thing I ever saw the
Rockefeller rocketeers dance right
question so so can you pull up the
picture by the way of the vaccine dance
yeah that was here so so here's here
here's a question for you here's a
question for him oh by the way there's a
question for all of us here
how much of it do you think they fear uh
don't play this right now what can come
back to this I mean we've all seen this
pathetic performance that they had which
was
uh uh but how much of this Tom Ed do you
think it's
they fear
that if they were wrong they worry that
a guy like Trump is going to come out
and his entire campaign is not going to
be let's make America great again it's
not going to be I'm with her it's not
going to be forward it's not going to be
dream it's going to be told you so can
you imagine if Trump's campaign slogan
is Told You So Right can you imagine if
this guy comes out and saying it's not
about America first it's about told you
so I told you Russia I told you vaccine
I told you I told you I so where they
are fearing
they're fearing if a guy like that comes
out holy moly they do not want that guy
to be right or or or
is it singular to one personality which
is Trump or is it singular to
the anti-establishment that questioned
The Narrative that's questioning the
traditional educational route that
people are taking right now that's
questioning grooming that's questioning
this censorship that's questioning all
of that is there fear that entire
community of influencers that have been
calling them out that they could
potentially be right or is it singular
to one personality that they fear Him
using this against them which one do you
think it is I I think if you get a
unified populace because you know
there's one thing the American voter has
been unified on on the last was it 35
years is that Congress only gets a 22
percent approval rating right never mind
the president's privileging rising and
falling Congress has been a 22 approval
rating and during Trump's campaign
forget that it was Trump the messaging
drained the swamp whoever you are as a
candidate was very effective as American
people because it lines up with their
notion well you know Congress is a is a
cesspool or a swamp whatever you want to
call it anyway and so if you move from
drain the swamp
to throw out the proven Liars then you
open up the opportunity and I'm going to
use a word here
um remember Mussolini came to power
among other things with I'm just gonna
make the trains run on time and you
can't trust anybody else it does open
the door for not you know dictatorial
Psychopaths like Mussolini but it opens
a door for a compelling personality to
rise on the incredibly not just
disappointed but now Angry populace you
know you had a low approval rating for
years drain the swamp I agree with now
you're you're not just liars you're
proven liars and you all gotta go and it
opens the door for that personality
to take that to take that vacuum and
drive it
you know for I have to ask the question
why now What's the timing three years
after what many of us suspected and knew
in 2020 that it was a lab leak you
didn't have to have too many brain cells
to figure that out why now What's the
timing and I think it's a distraction
from what I continue to believe is the
most horrendous crime ever which is this
vaccine fraud because the death and
disabilities continue and they need to
blame somebody and why not China
and and take the blame off of them for
introducing the vaccines because the U.S
is the one that wrote the vaccine wave
and we're the ones responsible for it
I just unpacked that I'll pack that with
China so you're thinking you're thinking
they're they're sitting there saying yet
let's unifying go against China
and say that it was their fault
and to hope that we win the election
again
uh
if you do that
you're only like okay so if you know how
let's just say a president prior to you
had these 10 policies he chose to drive
okay
he's a one-term president you win you
say we're gonna stop that with this
thing and we're gonna say that was a bad
idea three years later out of the ten
things you cancel nine of them
now you bring back nine of them
guess what the other side is going to
say this is the opening remarks on my
first speech
when I was President I pitched these 10
things you guys said you didn't want me
you wanted a guy named Joe no problem
you got him
he turned off my nine ideas on what I
said but three years later every one of
the things he canceled he realized were
the Right Moves he brought it back up so
all along you really just wanted me
that's going to be the campaign so I
don't think
that can be the case because that just
speaks into Trump's narrative I think
that they may have to speak speak into
Trump's narrative because the Deep State
and and the people involved in all this
I mean this this is the most horrendous
thing that's ever happened to our
country the numbers are Stark I haven't
even talked about the disabilities the
deaths are bad but the disabilities are
affecting the economy for sure what do
you mean by Rob were you going to ask
something or say something it just it
seems odd the timing of everything
that's going on between Russia China
aligning together and now all of a
sudden we've had this big push in the
United States to back Ukraine and now
all of a sudden after three years are
coming out and saying well it was China
it was China China did this yeah well
could it be that they're trying to align
and gather citizens of the United States
to look at China and go well look what
China did now China's aligning
themselves with Russia now we're going
to throw our full support behind Ukraine
almost to unite us much like after 9 11
9 11 happened Patriot Act happens we in
we go into Iraq and Afghanistan and all
of a sudden there was this sense
patriotism we haven't had that sense of
patriotism in this country since 2015
2014 and now all of a sudden hey we have
a common enemy could that common enemy
be China because China may be aligning
themselves with Russia well China so
that's a good point by the way no I
agree with that uh look China conflict
with China and Russia
right now it's done through proxy with
the Ukraine we're not
currently involved kinetically with
China and Russia but
I I'm predicting that unfortunately
that's going to come to a head in the
next couple of years if not sooner
primarily because we have a sovereign
debt crisis you know that's unfolding
the monetary system as we know is kind
of unraveling and also we have this
vaccine crime so wouldn't it be nice to
wipe both issues off the face of the map
with War I think war is inevitable I
hate to say it but I think that's where
we're headed oh that that part I agree
because because what historically what
happens when America has been in war
they typically re-elect that President
yeah because they don't want a
disruption that's just Studies have
shown right if we're we're in War uh uh
the same presidents gets reelected so
there's many different cards you can use
for re-election that's definitely one of
them and we're definitely heading in
that direction how bad and ugly it's
going to be nobody knows some are even
saying we're already in war we're just
you know using a country
proxy war that we're using Ukraine as a
way of going against Russia but for me
this is all playing into the hands of
one guy you know it's all playing into
the hands of one guy you can love the
guy you can hate the guy I don't care if
he is wanting to have a campaign
and name the slogan anything he can name
it told you so it's a campaign called I
Told You So by the way if the campaign
made a shirt called I Told You So with
his face on it it would sell millions
I'm telling you right now if Trump's
campaign if they sold a shirt right now
it would be the new Mega it wouldn't you
know how the Maga had blew up and it was
all over the place all he needs to do is
add a new product to it called I Told
You So by the way even check to see if
they have that product already or not
type in Trump I Told You So shirt
and see if it's on their website have
you seen the meme uh uh I identify as a
conspiracy there you go yeah they need
they need to make that as their what
website is that at by the way is that
them selling it that's Amazon no no they
need to sell it they need to sell it
they need to sell a merge called I told
you so and I think that would sell so
well if they keep going this direction
this is why if I'm if I'm a democratic
strategist I'm like listen guys here's
what you have to realize
if you keep going the direction you're
going to trash China
you're probably not going to get
reelected because all they're going to
say is we were right all along
you have to take a different page to
show Trump was wrong they can't show
Trump being right and too many of the
decisions they're making right now
they're Sean Trump was right you you
strategically that's a dumb move they're
making it's just my opinion I'm not a
political strategist just somebody
thinking about it I don't think that's
the right move they're making so okay
let's go to the next one let's go to the
next one by the way before I go into the
next one with
the BBC story about the cover-up text
messages that leaked uh what stats did
you want to share about the disabilities
yeah that's important yeah the
disability data is pretty Stark so
um since the introduction the vaccines
disabilities have taken off Nationwide
and I'm using U.S Bureau Labor
Statistics so prior to covid for the
prior five years we had about 29 to 30
million disabled Americans just bouncing
up and down around February of 21 it
took off and it went up into the right
uh concurrent with the vaccine uptake we
do statistical analysis it's like a 0.9
r squared fit that's geek speak for uh
there's there's some correlation there
now they'll say correlation is not
causation whatever
um but since the introduction of the uh
vaccines we went to a high of 33.2
million uh disabled folks in September
22. uh so again I told you 29 to 30
million was the average prior five years
so we added 3.2 million in about 18
months when you break down the data of
of the uh uh 3.2 1.7 million is employed
so the employer having a tough time
excessive death and disability what are
the disabilities that are that it
doesn't it just it's just it's a one and
a zero they don't get into the granular
it's just it's just raw numbers so I'm
saying there's a signal here I don't
need to go any further than that that's
a big number it's a 10 increase overall
uh the rate of change in growth was a
three sigma event three standard
deviation happens point zero three
percent of the time point zero three
percent of the time not point three
percent you said a 10 change but I'm
looking here at 3.1 percent to almost
4.1 percent so that's like one over
three that one that's thirty three
percent well I was about to get into
that so for the employed uh their
disability rate went up 31 the general
U.S population's disability rate went up
nine percent
than not in labor force those who quit
or got fired who could have been in the
labor force their disability rate went
up four percent so whatever's going on I
think it's the vaccine something is
happening to the employed people of our
country they're dying excessively and
they're getting disabled faster so I
when I went before Senator Johnson in
December I said we have a national
security issue here now if you don't
believe me it's the vaccine then what is
it why aren't we talking about it
because the the employed of our country
are dying faster than everybody else and
getting disabled faster and when you
break it down between employed men and
women women are getting smoked women
women's disability rate increases 39 men
19. why is that whatever uh this night
uh Dr Naomi wolf has done some analysis
of the clinical clinical uh trials at
Pfizer and the the incidence of Adverse
Events affected women they saw about 70
of the Adverse Events were women that's
that's that fits with the data from the
US Bureau of Labor Statistics again two
different studies showing the same thing
um uh someone just put out a piece today
I retweeted it I forget her name but uh
she basically said that whatever's going
on is affecting whatever's going on is
affecting women and it has something to
do with the menstrual cycle the spike
protein it's a disaster it's interesting
a 33 increase in the disability rate
here and also you gave us some numbers
on uh mortality excess excess death
rates that were also 33 to 50 percent up
so it's kind of interesting that these
two families of stats being disabled or
dying or both up excess that was uh
excess death rate correct yeah both up
33 and both up starting third quarter
2020.
yeah
what are you thinking
it's they're they're rising at the same
time so whether you're disabled or or
you die it's very
very
nervous that both of those stats are
going up
33 percent over that time consistent
with people getting the vaccine so
disability rates up 33 starting third
quarter of 2020. you know excess death
rates up 33 to 50 depending on the
cohort you're talking about starting
third quarter of 2020 going forward so
it says that once the vaccine's
introduced it started February 21.
right I was going back I guess February
21 I was going back to end of 2020 when
the oh yes yeah the big ramp of stabs
happen because Supply caught up and
there was mass facts actually it's
underway yeah
uh pretty disturbing data yeah yeah look
so 1.7 million unemployed people is 1.7
of the workforce about 100 million
employed in the U.S so if you're
wondering why there's a labor shortage
part of the reason is due to disability
and people just quietly just
disappearing from the workforce some
people are actually working with
disabilities and that's another issue so
so this leads me to the Reuters article
fact check video claiming covid-19
vaccine left 13 627 debt and 17794
disabled is sourced from an unverified
vaers data this is a Reuters article if
you want to go to that right there a
video being shared online that's gone
viral uh Advanced Event Systems uh U.S
vaccine investors reporting systems
which reported not to prove casualty if
you can go a little lower
video we're going to the comments are
saying not doing it these numbers are
based on reports not actual diverse
events and that's confirmed by Senator
Disease Control as shown uh VA ERS
welcome Healthcare Providers vaccine
manufacturers and Publications or he
warns that the data on the site may
contain information that is incomplete
inaccurate coincidental and unfair why
are they so worried about just
investigating this all you have to do is
a journalist from the left here let's
look at this data according to the CDC
guidance listed on his page reporting
Adverse Events from covid-19 vaccines
here there has been 6968 reports of
death
um recorded from December 14 to 2020 to
August 23 2021 among people who receive
the covid-19 vaccine it is important to
note that the FDA requires Healthcare
Providers to report any death after
covid-19 vaccination to vaers even if
it's unclear whether the vaccine was the
cause Reuters has debunked similar
claims that vaers had data has implied
casualty here and here
okay keep going lower
what is their worry about this
so there's uh normally would have sent
us in February of 2021 the doctors the
front line doctors said that this
product should have been pulled because
we had a death signal from vars but it's
been ignored Bears is the the vaccine
injury database and you know in 1976
when we had the swine flu they pulled
that after 25 deaths and Verge is over
17 000 now so I don't you know this is
this most Bizarro thing I've ever seen
in my life the fact that this is
continuing I mean the mere fact I'm on
the scene here is a problem why is a guy
from Wall Street having to do this this
should have ended in the earliest days
of the vaccination can you repeat what
you just said about swine flu you you
went really quick over that I want to
make sure people hear what you just said
yeah so in 1976 there was a swine flu
vaccine that was created and it was
there was a big Push by the president a
lot of celebrities sounds similar 25
deaths and they pulled it
pulled the vaccine off Market off Market
ended the program
so apparently life's gotten a lot
cheaper
in the last 40 years
and again if you talk to some of the
doctors that have been censored and
maligned and smeared they will tell you
there was a safety signal in theirs and
if everything was operating properly
like it was in the 70s this would have
ended in March of 2021 they would have
pulled the damn thing
but here we are today you got me the the
fact that I'm on the scene is sad
because there's enough uh ones and zeros
that I can count them
and I shouldn't be here I should not be
a public figure I should be on Maui on
the beach relaxing and here I am
because no one else seems to do it well
on behalf of fauci we'd like to
apologize for you not having enough time
on the boat you know but let's go let's
go to this to the story that you have
from BBC or radar online I'll just read
this to you covet cover-up leaked text
messages show British Health Minister
suggesting to deploy new virus variant
to frighten the pants off everyone
how in the hell is this leaked WhatsApp
messages has revealed that Matt Hancock
the former Secretary of State for health
in Britain attempted to frighten the
public into compliance
with covid-19 restrictions the Sunday
Telegraph obtained the messages in which
Hancock appeared to suggest to a top
aide when to reveal the existence of
Kent variant of kova to ensure people
comply with new lockdown rules in
another conversation uh Simon case the
head of Britain Civil Service emphasized
the importance of fear guilt factor in
the government's messaging these
messages are part of over a hundred
thousand leaked by a journalist Isabel
okep
who defended their release as being in
an overwhelming public interest the
leaks have raised questions about the
handling of the pandemic in the UK and
other countries around the world what
are your thoughts on this year
uh this is a bombshell I mean this is
unbelievable this is this is so what's
going on right now and you guys are
probably noticing the information is
coming Fast and Furious like there's
leaks there's things it seems like
there's a mass Awakening going on this
is just unbelievable and I I saw one of
the uh I don't know if you just read it
but the one about about the you know I I
just got tedro's his chips
he talked about shipping people his chip
vaccine I'm not sure there's a chip in
there but he said it in one of the
leaked messages not on this one but it's
it this is unbelievable this is this is
this is the kind of thing let's let's
read this Matt Hancock we frighten the
pants off everyone with new strain but
the complication with that brexit is
taking the Top Line yep that's what
we'll get proper behavior change when do
we deploy the new variant been thinking
about that about this and think we need
to move be more cautious The Strain that
is think you made the point earlier but
we need to keep schools off paperwork
agenda yes we're doing a bit about not
not taking the top I think big risk with
the very end right wing papers go for
renewed push for
let it rip on the basis the vaccine
strategy is undermined
go a little higher I can't see it Rob
that's why we reassure
on the vaccine yeah I saw that a couple
days ago and then the new leak is him
talking about pushing the chip meaning
the vaccine can you find a new leak of
uh of the chip type and chip
go to the top and type in yeah there you
go anything comes up on about public
health he's talking about crowd control
and changing behavior and controlling uh
correct of course but but there was a
reference to a chip which people are
going crazy with I again this is just
pretty unbelievable this is about
control this is about power this is
about changing behaviors it had nothing
to do with the with the with public
health what's the outcome what are you
doing this for so is it here's the part
I don't care if you're left right middle
like the left doesn't benefit from this
this is this isn't like hey all the
Democrats unify to go up against and use
this to control the behavior you really
think like John F Kennedy Bill Clinton
Democrats want this like this is not a
Democrat Republican independent this is
not good for anybody it's tyranny it's
power who would want this though who
would want this you want to hear my
personal opinion but if you're going to
go to you know you know the Klaus Schwab
New World Order World economic is that
kind of where you're gonna go no no no
those guys seem to be fall guys at some
point they're clowns they're they're
caricatures are Bond you think cloud
Schwab was a clown he's not as strong as
people think no I'll I'll tell you what
I think this is a personal opinion and I
didn't put into my book because it
doesn't it doesn't lend to the fact that
we just got dead people and disabled
people but I think that prior to 2020
those of us in the financial Community
were looking for the end of the
everything bubble sovereign debt crisis
so you know you moved from bank fraud
and then 12 years later it's going to be
sovereign debt fraud at some point and
that we're looking for Sovereign Bond
debt collapse and wouldn't it be nice to
have a control system to manage riots
Bank runs and all sorts of things I
think there was an agenda that was
driven that's why there was such Global
messaging in unison it was about the
financial system collapsing you need to
control system in place and you know the
vaccine passport was going to lead to
the digital ID to the central bank
digital currency that's ultimately where
you want to go I think this is driven by
politicians and Central Bankers that's
my personal opinion I have no proof but
it makes the most sense to me you need a
control system in place before
everything collapses you don't put big
Pharma oh big Pharma is a beneficiary of
that and they slap together and a tool
and a tool right here we go no promises
but I'm trying to land a Bill Gates
endorsement of the platform uh who is
Damon pool by the way tell him that
considering how many people I'm getting
his chips injecting into he owes me one
what there you go yeah so that now you
see what yeah that's crazy yep
so you know what's interesting I I'm on
your page uh because I believe who's
this guy damn in pool though
go back to this article zoom out let me
read this here uh is this this is MSNBC
this is MSN this is not fox or breitbull
this is MSN these are real mad Hancock
cracks joke about Bill Gates covet
conspiracy
the then Health secretary was hoping to
get Microsoft billionaire Gates help in
promising an offer uh to of you okay
expert to promote UK expertise in an
identifying coronavirus variants when he
made the chip in January 2020. at the
time the internet was Awash with
crackpot claims that the vaccination
program was being used as a means of
control in the world's population by
implanting my a microscopic uh chips
into people's arms some of them
suggested the Evil Genius behind the
plot of Mr Gates who was once
the world's richest man on January 25th
2021 Damon Poole Mr Hancock's media
advisor sent him a WhatsApp message
asking him if he had spoken to Ted Rose
the director general of the World Health
Organization about the new Varian
assessment platform which offered other
countries UK expertise to detect and
assess new variants around the world
okay many of the conspiracy theories
about the covet vaccine were said to
have been spread on the Internet by Pro
Kremlin Outlets Pro Kremlin Outlets of
course they included a suggestion that
Mr Gates wanted to implant tracking
devices inside every human through Mass
vaccination and that microchips
containing vaccines would allow
Microsoft to control the entire world
population the European Union even
issued the lengthy advice on how to
persuade people that the microchip plot
was fiction another popular conspiracy
theory is said to have been spread by
Russia was that Oxford University jab
was a monkey vaccine that not only uh
contravened animal rights but would also
turn people into monkeys Mr Gates did
not in the event indoors and VAP
you know I I don't know anything about a
chip but this is disturbing it's just
disturbing that he's saying this back
then well here's what I like what I like
about this is that
um MSNBC
you know a BBC is being forced to have
to show this correct the only reason
they're showing this is probably because
this was emailed to everybody these
pictures and said you best show it or
else so if others do and you don't
you're gonna look like a clown if these
things are being shown and of course
they're putting their spin on it which
is what they do that's by the way I
honestly don't care if you add your spin
on it it's totally fine that's what we
all do we add our own exact uh opinion
to it here's what I think is really
going on you may be wrong I may be wrong
they may be wrong but the fact that
you're talking about it the audience has
to uh the populace has to go Google and
do their own research and say holy [__]
this is not fake this is real great then
there's then starts the conversation
yeah did was he making a joke or was it
you know who knows but the fact that
conspiracies theorists said this three
years ago now it's popping up in this is
progress if you ask me by the way I I
see this as progress yeah information in
the public canvas progress
um I completely agree so there's
something that you you talked about and
I've believed for a long time that
what happened in Greece 11 years ago oh
I would I remember that vividly and I
know and I'm connecting the dots here
because it goes right to France six
weeks ago where they said three things
the government is broke
so therefore you have to work longer
until you retire because we're broke we
don't have anything to give you and oh
by the way through a thing called the
austerity program in Greek there's a
Greek word for it in English translate
austerity you will be getting less
government benefits translation less
social security and Medicare they have a
socialized medicine there but there's
certain rationing of things unless
you're walk in with a compound fracture
or your leg of course they'll take care
of you
so those three things flipped out Greece
and you had you had a barbell shaped
protest meaning there is something on
both ends you had older workers walking
in the street saying I worked all my
life and I'm going to get less and I
can't retire for five more years and
then on the low end you had the
non-college educated youth that were
saying Hey I want my lifetime job at the
post office on the government Dole I'm
not going to get that because my grandpa
has to work five more years so where's
my free government job you see and then
there was the riots and the younger side
took over and they were burning the cars
so it started out that that was 11 years
ago what just happened in France is
eerily similar except it was that you
didn't have the kind of there was like
11 days of riots and fires and things
that were there in Greece but the same
thing happened
you have to work longer
our spreadsheet is constrained our
government spreadsheet and you're going
to have less benefits when you get there
all of those things are connected to
sovereign debt problems yeah and so what
happens is there's only two ways out of
this and this is not Tom speaking look
it up do all the research you want way
number one actually way a not in any
order is to inflate your way out through
a dramatic level of multi-year crisis
because then the government debt is paid
off with cheaper money and they inflate
their way out crushing the citizenry
the second way out is the Jubilee or
what's also known as Grand resets which
are negotiated settlements and currency
wipeouts at the end of global war
defaults correct basically yeah which is
easy to administer at the end of the war
you lost whoever you are I won your
currency is wiped out along with the
debt we reset and away we go there's the
only two ways and sometimes the first
one is called the Jubilee will declare
the Year of Jubilee and we will reset
the currencies because we've settled the
conflict good news we all go into the
future
and that's and I I happen to agree with
you I think there's there when all of
these
when all of the chickens come home to
roost on this one they need something to
cover there needs to be a triggering
mechanism there needs to be an excuse
the only the only narrative that can
deliver inflation sustained for long
enough to monetize the debt to get out
of this other than default is war that's
the only narrative that the public could
rally around
if they were propagandized properly and
believed in the righteousness of
whatever we're doing
but that's the only narrative yeah
that's what I was referencing is the
negotiated settlement to a war oh well
what happened to Canada's currency it
was a war we had to figure this out and
this is what we're doing yeah and then
the citizen goes okay I guess we have to
do that yeah look the bottom line is 90
99 of the globe doesn't know this but
the social contract has been broken most
of the governments are broke they can't
pay out all the the uh the benefits the
pensions especially Europe Europe the
Euro as we know it's not a question of
if but when it dissolves and southern
Europe is basically Germany is floating
floating everybody else's uh free party
down in southern Europe we have a
demographic problem how long is that
sustainable for though you know I I if I
that's the thousand dollar question
because then you can make a lot of money
but so timing is always a lot more than
a thousand bucks that's you know you can
make some real money with that one by
the way over 27 27 months I think if you
look it up that was where the mass of
George Soros wealth was created was in
currency hedging over a 27-month period
isn't that correct yeah
yes uh what recently no no no no oh yeah
he broke he broke the uh pound yep yeah
that's how he made it and and the money
he made was ridiculous yeah what you
just said if you you know you can make a
lot of money if you know when and going
back in history that's where that's
where he did it that made him who he is
today that was that was his big and you
know he did I suspect he did that with
inside info basically being friendly
with all the people inside but and by
the way it's funny because another story
came out about cnnx uh boss Jeff Zucker
told staff not to probe lab League
Theory because it was Trump Talking
Point again he's talking like a
strategist I agree with them for
Democrats it's good to not to do that
right because he's talking like a
democratic strategist he's not talking
like a seal the media company correct to
seal the media company needs to go out
there and tell the story so people keep
watching your show and watching your
content versus we don't trust you
anymore now they're in the gutter with
the views but let's talk about the
market place right now Tom you saw some
data on um
data that came out with mortgages today
with home prices today you mind getting
into that yeah there was a Roundup
article that was in the what I mean by
Roundup in the Wall Street Journal today
they were talking about housing market
momentum stalls this critical spring
season approaches and what they rounded
up into this correct was quantitative
look at all the elements that are there
right now for instance interest rates
that had started going down in November
have now picked back up to 6.65 and some
of that the bonds that determine
mortgage interest rates are already
expecting at least a quarter point in
about a week 16th 17th the FED goes out
yeah I think so along with and that's
also that's also a day where they
announce all the economic stats I think
this is a stats release as well and
mortgage applications right now
the lowest it's ever been in how long
you want to take yes how many years
mortgage applications lowest that
they've been in 28 years holy [__] right
now and according to this article yep
and the article's just pulling out with
what the journal is doing is they pulled
together all the stuff in one place and
they said you know you've got Supply the
new listings are down another 20 year
over year and you've got march to June
what they're worried about here is the
stock market looks for
all of the mortgage industry to have a
really good second quarter because March
to June it's sort of like if you think
of Black Friday for electronics and Q4
is really good for electronics and TVs
and phones and all that second quarter
is always historically just a party if
you're in the mortgage industry because
40 of the transactions of houses happen
right before school's out and right at
schools out April to June
and the journal is pointing out that
that's off another 40 percent and the
supply it says is stable but it's
sitting because there are experts in
there that said in 17 years over the
last 17 years the buying consumer has
never been this demonstrably rate
sensitive that happened as a result of
how many years of two to three percent
mortgages and they're getting their
heads around well it's up three times
when does it go back down because for
most of their buying lifetime they've
had this artificial two and a half three
percent interest rate and so this
article today in the journal just really
I was surprised to see the journal put
it all together all the stats no
suppositions no Spin and just saying hey
we're about to have a not fun
um March excuse me April to June which
is normally party time in uh in housing
and you know who was winning today Wall
Street Journal is winning today I got to
tell you if if there is a paper I read
every day for the last year now it's
Wall Street Journal they're telling the
story from a very independent standpoint
there is not a like you almost don't
feel opinion and hate and anger it's
just here's what's going on here's what
you got to look at this is what's going
on in history it is if you're going to
trust specifically from they've always
had a very good reputation but
specifically right now people don't
trust anybody like where do I go to read
They're crushing it right now yeah this
is not a story that's LED with CEO of Re
Max says it's going to be fine just give
me a minute you know you don't have any
of that that you know what I'm saying
sort of Industry puff pieces no there's
nothing and I was I looked at it and
it's what we've been saying that the
everybody thinking that five and a
quarter is going to be the top end for
the Fed rate is wrong uh Larry Summers
over the weekend was actually openly
campaigning and telling the FED you're
behind the curve on this one you need to
put a half a point on the next rate
increase and then two more quarters
you're behind the curve in other words
he's saying Jay Powell you you need to
do more on the interest rate to get
inflation under control than you're
doing right now and when you went to
quarter points and fourth quarter you
actually allowed inflation a chance to
reheat a little bit now whether that's
all comes to pass but it was um kind of
a dark a dark weekend because it
certainly doesn't look like rates are
going to be coming down now before you
know third quarter and that's what
everybody's saying even the Bulls and
the Bears are all in agreement if he
raises them a half now he's probably
raising a quarter quarter on the next
two meetings we're Suddenly at five
seven five uh the Fed rate and that's
housing is not going to bounce back
until we get three drops now that's
looking like September November earliest
so it may be a 24 recovery on uh housing
market or shall we say statistical
relief so that the market can recur
however as people put their houses on
the market or go buy something rather
than a second half of 23. and how high
does this go right because the FED fund
rate ran out right now is four and a
half give or take and then I think the
historical long-term average is 4.6 and
then you know what repeating history or
being a student of History I'm always
shocked to find out that in the 80s that
mortgage rates were double digits yeah
12 15 20 what like those are credit card
numbers of what you used to get a
mortgage for right it's insane to me
what was your first year you bought a
house by the way uh for sure I bought a
house was I was 26 and I think I got a
seven percent mortgage and what year was
that so
26 62 26 that was 88 yeah yeah it was 88
and that's that that would have been a
great rate in the late 80s yeah seven
and a half by the way I remember talking
to the guy that was doing my mortgage
and feeling like I just locked in on a
little dip he just hooked you up and
right now I mean mortgage rates are six
and a half percent I'm just saying like
as someone that is you know likes to
keep their money in cash and invest and
rent and kind of invest the difference I
don't even know when a good time to even
think about buying right now is six and
a half the bottom or are we gonna are we
trending towards double digits that's
insane to me and that's what the journal
was talking about is that there's
experts out there that are saying
they're saying objectively objectively
not opinion
buyers in their mid-30s right now have
never seen interest rates like that and
these are the most rate sensitive buyers
that they've ever seen
yeah if you're a millennial and you're
looking to buy a house you all you're
all you're used to is zero one two three
four like and all of a sudden it's six
seven by the way Uncle Adam talked to
his friend Tom about six points
this is where we need to stay
I I know this is not popular but this is
what we need to stay you know we keep
talking about how much fake money was
made 128 economic months economic
expansion covet doesn't come that could
have gone another Euro too could have
been 150 months you know it's not you
take over that it's 150 months you're
keeping rate says whatever it was and
people are just funding everything this
is where it needs to stay for a minute
okay the problem is going to happen Tom
is let's just say inflation does drop to
two percenters ago okay guess what let's
start lowering it again no no no pump
the brakes if you really wanted to start
breathing a little bit you got to get
off of steroids and growth hormone for a
couple of years okay that's right we've
been on it for way too long so that part
No One's Gonna know because who's going
to replace Jerome Powell who who the
hell is going to reflect you know how
last time we're having a conversation
with Crowder and the question was so
Susan stepped down right I was like well
you know what the great in story Susan
uh from YouTube
[Music]
from YouTube just step down and because
she did this this this wrong well the
person that replaced her worse is worse
is what the fear is like hey Jack
dorsey's stepping about time Jack Dorsey
steps down from Twitter no bro you wanna
Jack Dorsey to stay exactly the guy that
replaced him his War so as much as
people are you know giving a Powell a
hard time that he's pounding people on
upstairs and I know you always talk
about his bedroom activity
this is an inside joke for Tom Tom's got
very interesting
the economy as a poor cheerleader up in
her bedroom and that Jerome Powell is
going to keep pounding that cheerleader
till her parents come home and parents
coming home two percent interest rates
so but the new CEO of of uh YouTube is
Neil Mohan and you're saying that he's
saying that I'm not saying they are
saying I'm not the question is sometimes
you have to you know you have to worry
who's luck for example okay we gotta get
rid of Putin who who's replacing them
yeah right we got to get rid of yeah
okay who's replacing him so that is just
as much of a concern as it is at least
you have enough data to know how this
person is going to be right the markets
don't like uncertainty so just get the
guy in until this phase is over because
you switch mid mid mid game people will
be like I got to figure out the new guy
I actually think Powell's doing an okay
job I was just gonna ask I don't know if
I'm gonna sit here
goat or he's doing I agree I actually
think he is if you look at him compared
to some of the other guys I think he's
actually doing an okay job he's doing
way better than grandma
then Janet Yellen yes yeah I mean
that's not even a question uh uh uh but
but yeah so he so here's a question for
you have you ever had any interactions
with Michael burry have you ever done
anything no no why is he so low-key he's
on Twitter one day he shuts it down
comes back again tweets closes it again
doesn't do interviews doesn't talk to
people strong Insight very interesting
he's been right one too many times
what do you know about Michael burry
well so after the housing crisis he made
a speech excoriating Congress saying
that they all knew this was coming it's
all their fault then he started being
investigated by the feds and tax and IRS
so ever since that experience after the
housing crisis I don't think he is one
to be on the public stage but he is he
he knows what's going on with the code
with vaccines because he's intimated
that he's investing in some of these uh
plays on that and stop stock individual
basis like buying blood thinning
companies and shorting other companies
so he's already playing the covet
vaccine stuff
he to me he's a very interesting guy to
watch closely I see him as a stud I
think he's got courage I think he's
tough
um but I hope you know I was I I wish he
was a little bit more vocal yeah I think
it would be great if he came out and
gave his thesis on what's going on with
covert vaccine dude I would love nothing
more than to have a two-hour
conversation with this guy just to sit
down and say Michael what do we
expecting what's going on and by the way
I also think he's a crusade guy meaning
I think he's a True Believer I don't
think it's just about money for him I
don't think he's just like hey he wants
to get rich and you know go partying you
know Thailand and do whatever some of
these guys you know I think that's a guy
that really cares about what's going on
he has concerns he has good Insight I
think he needs to be more vocal so if
you know Michael burry if anybody knows
Michael Burr you're a friend of his or
your close colleague of his
you know kind of let him know I'd like
to talk but guess what I'm trying to say
you know I really like him I love him to
make a contra coveted
ETF and that way he'd have to go out
with investment letters because I'd love
to read those yeah okay well this has
been a fun podcast we've had a couple
things before we wrap up here one Tom
you launched your show yesterday uh uh
on your own channel bizdoc we're very
excited about it it was phenomenal can
you tell the audience what to expect
with your show before we wrap it up with
uh the the book here yeah the bizarre
prod podcasts are brought to you by
valuetainment thank you very much Pat Uh
every Monday 11 30 Eastern 8 30 Pacific
it's an hour stats stories and what it
means for you I like to find the story
behind the story and talk about what it
means for you know the valutainment
listener you know entrepreneurs leaders
people trying to make a mark owning
their own company working for people in
that and to give you uh something to
start the week with and the News you can
use
I love it so Monday at 11 30. Eastern 8
30 Pacific so before launch on the East
Coast yep right as you get to work on
the West Coast Live on YouTube and then
syndicated to all the places that the
valuetainment podcasts are syndicated
through our partner for Spotify and
others for those of you who love Tom
tune in uh we are doing one more podcast
this week tomorrow I believe it's at
four o'clock or three three o'clock
three o'clock Eastern Standard Time uh
we will have home team only we got a lot
of things that we have to talk about
that we haven't done for a week or so
and then we will not be doing any other
podcasts for the rest of the week uh we
did announce yesterday on Stephen
Crowder's podcast I want to tell it to
you guys again we're gonna we're gonna
launch ticket sales for the April 7th
live we're gonna do it this time at
night because we ran a survey and a lot
of you guys want this live podcast at
the studio to be night time not morning
time we're doing it Friday night at
seven to nine on April 7th uh we may
have some guests we're not going to
disclose it until you show up and see
who it is
the last time we did this we sold that
within a couple hours uh text the award
podcast to the number
310-3401132 again text the word podcast
to
310-340-1132 the moment we have tickets
for sale you'll be there some of you
guys VIP had a chance to go to the Cigar
Lounge at a hour conversation with a
bunch of different guys about what's
going on it was a phenomenal time we'll
love to see and meet many of you guys
who weren't there on the first one uh
that we had and last but not least Rob
let's put the link below to cause
unknown highly recommend everybody go
get a copy for themselves look through
the data look through the Articles look
through what he has in here and question
it why is this taking place
it's simply to question again and then
find from there have conversations
within people in your community Talk
Amongst each other talk to your family
talk to your relatives talk to your
co-workers what do you think about this
what are your thoughts about this have
you seen this year but start by ordering
the book cause unknown Rob let's make
sure that's below as well Ed appreciate
you for coming out here from uh Maui uh
uh I know you would much rather have the
lifestyle in Florida than the one in
Maui I love the weather here it's
awesome it's if we we love it here I
mean I've been to Maui one too many
times and I love it there as well we
went there one time years ago and we
walked on a volcano active volcano with
lava coming down and we have to get up
at four o'clock in the morning to make
it to the other side so we can walk
before the Ranger shows up and they told
us all the signs if it all of a sudden
starts raining if you smell this weird
smell and if the things you're walking
on is about to break if it does it's
game over for you walk back we got to
that point where we it was myself and a
couple of our friends John and uh um was
it Mario Jose was there and you were
walking there and also and Jose and I
step on this thing I'm like uh oh it's
time to walk back we walk back but we
have a lot of good memories and Hawaii
probably not one of the best decisions I
made in my life cause known
anyway decisions my friend
have a great one guys we'll see you
tomorrow Ed again thank you take care
everybody bye-bye bye-bye thank you guys